okay hi everyone
welcome to another episode of science
and technology q a
for kids and others we missed last week
because we're in the middle of our
summer programs with our summer school
high school summer camp
and more but uh taking a short break
from that here
to do some of these q a's um
all right let's see we had a whole bunch
of questions saved up
uh there's a question here um
is doing science something intrinsic to
the human species
so that if humanity were to be restarted
science would emerge afresh
boy that's an interesting question well
what is science
you know i think science is in large
part
about understanding and predicting
how the world is going to what what is
going to happen in the world
the science is about figuring out that
uh systematic facts about how the world
behaves
and in a sense any organism
that wants to sort of lead a happy life
has to implicitly do a certain amount of
science it has to know
oh if i bite this object
i will successfully be able to bite
through it it's soft enough that i can
bite through it
and uh you know berries that are colored
red
are sometimes poisonous and these other
kinds of things that we could think of
as sort of a a primitive form of science
these are systematic facts about the
world
that are worth knowing because they
allow you to
make your behavior be more likely to be
one that will be successful you'll
survive you'll produce lots of
uh lots of little critters and your
species will will keep going and so on
so i think it in in any uh in a sense
the
the prediction of things about the world
is something which is a pretty
definitive feature
of sort of organisms that are successful
in the world i mean
one of the things that happens is when
we look at the evolution of species
we see oh there's a species and
the species where there are more progeny
there are more
children of that species they'll have
more children they'll have more children
and so on
that species will tend to win out
relative to a species that has fewer
children
might have fewer children because well
that species
just eats the red berries all the time
and uh the or that variant of the
species
it is sort of genetically programmed to
say i see a red berry
that looks really good to eat let me go
ahead and eat it oops it was poisonous i
died
um and so the the the organisms where
they have a variation of their genetics
that causes their sort of built-in
program
to be such that it says eat red berries
that
they will not tend to have child
critters
that will share that genetics and so
that
line of genetics will tend to go extinct
as compared to the other one which says
you know eat orange berries or something
and uh
that will be very successful so so sort
of the simplest form of learning
for organisms is just by virtue of
what they're genetically programmed to
do
but one of the things that happened in
the history of biological evolution we
don't know exactly when
a couple of billion years ago i would
guess was
organisms kind of the the idea
of learning while you're alive so to
speak
uh came in and organisms would be such
that
they would have things that they didn't
intrinsically know when they were born
they were not genetically programmed
but they were things that they learnt in
the course of their life
and a lot of that learning probably has
happened in neural networks
in in brain like organs
or more primitive forms of brain like
things that have
sort of electrochemical neurons a bit
like the ones we have
that are capable of uh what one might
call habituating
remembering things noticing forming a
habit
knowing that if this happens that's
likely to happen next and so on
and i think that's sort of the most
primitive form of science
is this habituation of an organism to
know
that oh if you do this this is going to
happen
now the big thing that was the big jump
for our species is normally
there were sort of a couple of choices
either there were things that were sort
of known genetically and passed down but
from between generations of a species or
there were things where every individual
member of the species
had to kind of relearn that from a blank
slate
so you know there will be things that um
where
they would learn by actually
experiencing the world
etc that um this is how things work
well kind of a big additional moment
is taking knowledge that was accumulated
by one generation
and abstractly passing it to the next
generation
teaching the next generation something
or passing down knowledge
in some more abstract way than just
while you experience it for yourself and
learn from your experiences
and i don't know to what extent
different kinds of
organisms you know teach their progeny
to fly or whatever else
and to what extent it's just like try
flapping and see what happens
and eventually by experience you'll
learn it but i think that that's kind of
a
a critical feature of science as we know
it today
is that there's sort of an abstract
representation of this kind of knowing
systematic things about what's going to
happen in the world that
is capable of being communicated
abstractly
from one generation to the next so i
think that that's
a feature of of kind of that's been a
an important feature of our species we
don't know to what extent other species
share
the ability to have sort of linguistic
level communication
to be able to communicate abstract kinds
of ideas
but we certainly have that and in a
sense that's the core of our science
is the fact that not only are we able to
as individuals
learn from experience what
systematically happens in the world
but we're able to communicate it
abstractly to future generations so to
speak
and of course that that brings me to
where we are right now with my attempts
to um communicate kind of ideas about
science
to to people um there you know i'm i'm
just following the trend of the species
so to speak
in trying to do that but you know what
point
is there this abstract set of knowledge
that can be passed down that we would
call science
you know historically well in antiquity
people had sort of descriptions of the
world where they
said the world works in this or that way
sometimes they got it more or less right
sometimes they guessed
how the world works at a level below
where they could see the world so to
speak
and they didn't get it right we now know
they didn't get it right
but there were things that they
concluded about sort of systematic facts
about how the world works
about astronomy about medicine about
biology and so on
where yes they did correctly
abstract from the specific things they
saw
to sort of more general principles now
you know science as we think of it today
has gone through several kind of epochs
first was kind of the one in antiquity
in ancient greece and so on ancient
babylon
where people were kind of describing the
world
as it is put together in this or that
way the big thing that happened in the
1600s
was people realizing that you could use
mathematics and things like mathematical
formulas
to describe features of the world and
that
was a particular approach
that was very important for
understanding things like astronomy and
understanding things
about mechanics and so on and that sort
of developed from the 1600s 1700s 1800s
and so on
it progressively developed sort of the
use of mathematics
as a as a form of abstract
representation
of scientific knowledge it worked in
some areas like physics
some areas of physics it didn't work at
all well in areas like biology
except in very very specific cases and
generally the principle was
when things were happening that looked
very complicated
it wasn't possible to write down
equations for them but when things were
happening where it seemed very
systematic
it was possible to write down equations
for them and so on
i mean i started working in the 1980s on
sort of a different approach
using simple programs rather than
equations
to sort of represent things that happen
in the world and there are different
conclusions from doing that you can have
a program that represents a very simple
program
that says this and this and this are the
rules for what happens but when you run
the program
the actual behavior you get may be very
complicated and there's a whole
kind of new kind of science as i've
called it
that uh has to do with understanding
sort of the the general principles
of operating in a case like that
but so the question was being asked here
was would science
reoccur rearrise if humanity were to be
restarted
i think the first point is just by
virtue
of kind of doing the things we do
in sort of leading our lives there is a
certain amount of prediction of how the
world works
that we have as do other species
and that is something that definitely
restarts
if the new humanity isn't going to go
extinct
now the question is what forms of
abstraction
would there be that allow you to to sort
of have an
abstract representation of what happens
in the world and
are there different kinds of abstract
representations of what happens in the
world
that might arise my guess is the answer
that is yes there are different forms of
abstraction
for example the fact the things i
figured out about sort of
the computational view of the world were
figured out in the 1980s
and the things people figured out about
kind of the the
mathematical view of the world were
figured out in the more like the 1680s
the fact that there was that uh kind of
300 year difference
in that direction i think is a is a
detailed feature
of the evolution of technology for our
species and i'm not sure it had to be
that way
i think it could have been that the
computational view arose actually before
the mathematical view so science
as we have it might be very different if
history was replayed
but i think the idea that there are
abstract principles
that govern the operation of the world
that's something that's sort of i think
a largely inevitable
consequence of of of going above
kind of these specific experiences that
an individual organism might have
that allow it to make sort of local
predictions about the world
let's see another question here from rbs
can i talk about pseudo-random
linear congressional
uh pseudonym number generators
okay we can talk a little bit about that
okay
you say that you want your computer to
give you a random number
let's say you're using that because
i don't know you're you're uh you're
sitting with your friend and you're
trying to work out
who's going to get the bigger piece of
pie and you're going to decide
that on the basis of a random number
you're going to say generate that random
number by computer
and let's say you say well from language
in a random integer
and then it will say zero one with
equal probability so there's a question
how did it do that how did it work that
out
let's say we say generate a million
random numbers
ones and zeros for example what is it
actually doing
well it's
what we have to sort of talk about what
is randomness
randomness actually it relates a bit to
the answer i was giving to the question
about sort of the nature of science
randomness is something where you don't
know what's going to happen
let's say we're generating zeros and
ones randomly
with equal probabilities that means
you're going to get another digit out
you're going to get another number out
and you simply know nothing about what
that next number is going to be
all you know is that in the long run
they'll be about equal numbers of zeros
and ones
but each particular one you
are completely unable to predict that's
sort of operationally what it means for
that number to be
random now the question is if you're
generating those numbers on a computer
how are you actually going to do it
so you know what is it in the world
that's random so to speak
well we could imagine you know in in uh
i don't know whether they still do these
on television and so on where they're
doing sort of lottery picks where one
hopes you know
the the lottery is going to be picked at
random what's going to happen
and they might do something where they
have a whole bunch of uh
ping pong balls or something they put
them all in a big container
and they blow air around the container
of the balls sort of randomly flap
around
and then somebody reaches their hand
then and picks out a ball
and because there was sort of that
random process
of fluid mechanics and motion of air and
balls
randomly bouncing around you say well
it's kind of random what ball will be
picked out
and that's random enough that we can use
it to define
who wins the lottery or whatever that's
that's kind of an approach to making
randomness
by using kind of physical processes
where you just kind of
it's complicated enough you kind of
don't really know what's happening
and so you say well i just can't predict
anything let's consider it random
different example of that would be coin
tossing so
you think about you flip a coin you
maybe flip it from your finger you flip
it up in the air it turns over a bunch
of times
and then it lands heads or tails okay
what determines which way up it actually
lands
well it's flipping around in the air
let's say it flips around 50 times in
the air
and it sort of depends in great detail
which
flip number you know it actually
lands at let's say it lands at flip 48
then maybe it will be heads if it lands
at flip 49
it will be tails and so the you have to
kind of define
in other words if you if you were able
to sort of watch
the thing turning over and turning over
and maybe every even numbered flip it
was heads let's say
every odd number flip it was tails and
you were to catch it at the right flip
then you could always determine what the
what the result would be
so why is coin tossing random it's
random because
when you you know flip the coin up in
the air with your thumb
it's very hard for you to determine
exactly how fast the coin is going
so you can't really determine exactly
how high it will go
exactly how many times it will turn over
before it hits the table again
and you've determined whether it's heads
or tails
so it's kind of the the un
uncontrollability
of exactly how fast you flip your thumb
that is what causes the result of the
coin toss to be random
so if you had a machine in a carefully
calibrated machine that's doing those
coin tosses
and you carefully calibrate exactly what
speed it flips the coin at
well then the coin toss will no longer
be random
because it will always come out as the
same result because the machine is
always
sending it out at exactly the right
velocity and so on
but you just can't do that as a
practical matter perhaps with enough
training you could do that with your
thumb
too but typically one doesn't one isn't
able to determine
uh that as precisely with one's thumb so
to speak
and so that's why the we can say that
the result of the coin tossing
looks random so these kind of physical
sources of randomness like that
another one would be you have a bunch of
molecules bouncing around in a room
that are bouncing around because they're
because there's a
they're not at zero temperature so they
sort of there's the energy of associated
with heat
that's bouncing all these molecules
around and there are
trillions and trillions and trillions of
molecules in the room and you don't know
where all of them are positioned
and so to you they look random and if
you can have some effect
that depends on exactly which molecule
hit
what hits what when that is for all
practical purposes
random because you just don't know
enough to be able to predict it
so these are methods for kind of getting
physically based randomness
another way of getting randomness would
be the following you say
i'm going to ask for that random integer
okay and i'm going to press
shift enter and more from language to
get the random integer
okay exactly when did you press that
can you determine that to 1 millionth of
a second
no way unless you're doing it in some
automated fashion
if you're just pressing that button it's
kind of like well i'm just pressing it
when i feel like it
and the exact detailed precise time
as measured by the sort of the clock of
the internet the atomic clock
that uh determines time on the internet
you can't determine that exact time
and so the last few digits down to the
microsecond down to the millionth of a
second
will be for all practical purposes
random so that's another way to generate
sort of a
a pretty good random number is just by
when did you exactly ask for it
it's it's uh that you can't because you
can't determine that
that will be to you something that seems
unpredictable and random
of course if you do something like you
say well actually i'm going to generate
a hundred random numbers in parallel on
all the different cores of my computer
and you press the shift enter and they
all boom they all generate at the same
time
or they all generate in just the time
that it took
some some data to be communicated from
one process on your computer to another
well then those random numbers won't be
so different because they'll all be
generated at the same time or very close
to the same time
all those digits will be the same and
you'll say oh whoops
those weren't really random numbers it
was once i had one of them
all the others were predictable okay so
when you write programs on computers you
often want
lots and lots of apparently random
numbers
let's say you're trying to figure out
something like um you're trying to do a
calculation where
you say i want a sample uh what happens
in lots of different cases
in this particular kind of system and
you just want to sample them at random
then you need to pick lots of quotes
random numbers
to determine what those samples will be
okay how do you do that well
what you do is you use a an algorithm a
program for making random numbers
now at some level you say that has to be
a cheat because if there's a program for
making those numbers
then it is predictable you just have to
know the program and then you can know
what numbers you'll generate
but here's a an interesting fact which
is actually a core fact of this whole
uh kind of science that i've developed
based on looking at kind of
what programs typically do you can have
even a very simple program
and where you know exactly what the
program is but when you run the program
the things it generates will be very
hard to compute
in fact the only way to compute them is
just to like run the program keep
running the program keep running the
program see what it generates
we know of examples of that even in sort
of basic mathematical kinds of things
like
pi 3.141592653 etc etc etc that is
generated by a comparatively simple
program
that is working out essentially the
ratio of the circumference to diameter
of a circle
and it's generating those digits but
once those digits have been generated
nobody's ever found any regularity in
those digits
beyond saying oh those are the digits of
pi
so for all practical purposes that's
something where you have a program
but when you generate digits from that
program
they seem completely random so
that's how pseudo-random generators
work in a computer they are essentially
algorithms
that have the property that even though
the
rule for the algorithm even though the
way of running the algorithm
is definable is straightforward it will
always be the same every time you run it
it is still the case that the results of
that algorithm
seem for practical purposes random it
means for example if you're generating
ones and zeros
there'll be an equal number of ones and
zeros there will be an equal number of
one zeros and zero ones
as as successive pairs there'll be other
kinds of properties that you would
expect
of a sequence that is perfectly random
of course if you hit exactly the right
thing and you say well
was it a sequence generated by this
particular uh
way of generating things well then it'll
say well actually no it's not random at
all
it was generated by this way of
generating things but for most uses of
that random sequence
they're not doing that they're saying oh
are there an equal number of zeros and
ones things like that
and so it will be good enough so how do
those
pseudo-random number generators actually
work the most common kind that was used
in the
in the distant past were things called
linear congruential generators
and the way those work and uh let me not
uh actually show this on a computer but
but
um the way they work is you
basically take the number you had
you multiply it by some other number you
add a number
and then you reduce it mod some other
number
so reducing mod means it's like when you
have a clock
and let's say you add hours on a clock
so you've got three o'clock
and you say three o'clock plus six okay
that gives you nine o'clock
plus six again instead of going
to um uh um
uh instead of going to 12
i'm sorry instead of going to um uh what
am i doing i'm doing
my arithmetic hopelessly instead of
going to 15
when you add six again to nine it's
on that circular clock face it cycles
back again
and you get back to three so that's
so-called modulo arithmetic
where you say well there's just a
limited number of numbers that you're
going to allow
and when it wraps around you'll just
you'll just allow it to wrap around
another way think about that
for example when you're computing things
mod 10
that's just like taking numbers written
out in
in decimal in in standard uh positional
notation
and just saying look at only the last
digit so you know you have the number
123
123 mod 10 is just three just the last
digit
and that's a general principle of
modular arithmetic if you work out
numbers mod 2 for example
that's like take the numbers in binary
arithmetic in binary notation
and just take the last digit which is 0
1 there
okay so the idea of a linear
congruential generator
is you're taking a number let's say you
get the number 17
no let's say you get the number and
then you're taking 10 times a constant
let's say the constant is 17
and then you add another constant let's
say that constant is 10
or something and then you take the
result let's say mod 10.
and you keep doing that you keep
iterating that
you keep just multiplying
adding reducing mod let's say 10.
okay so for certain choices of those
numbers
it takes a really long time for the
sequence to repeat
and the sequence of numbers you get out
is pretty random for other choices of
numbers it's not very random at all
but if you choose the numbers correctly
and you have primes and so on in there
it's pretty random i have to tell you a
story long ago
i was using a computer around 1980 i
think
i was using a computer that was
made by what used to be the world's
second largest computer company
digital equipment corporation and it had
a standard built-in random number
generator
pseudo-random number generator and i got
some really weird results
and i the first thing i thought about is
i wonder what their random number
generator is like
it was exactly one of these linear
congruential random number generators
and it turns out that if you take uh two
successive numbers
that are generated from that the number
of one iteration the number at the next
iteration
and you plot those one is on the x-axis
the others on the y-axis
for certain choices uh which might have
seemed like good choices
of those constants that you multiply and
add and so on by
you end up with all the numbers you get
out forming these kind of stripes
on this plot of number against next
number
so anyway that happened rather
dramatically for the built-in random
number generator
for that particular kind of computer
back in those days
so that's the feature of these so-called
linear congruential generators are these
a times n plus b mod m or something
uh type formulas and they end up getting
these stripes maybe they get stripes
when you plot
in two dimensions one number against the
next one maybe they get stripes in three
dimensions
when you plot three successive numbers
together but eventually they
end up always getting these kinds of
stripes and you can end up with
you can sort of minimize that effect
that
sort of non-randomness non-uniformity
by picking the correct numbers putting
the best numbers but you always get some
kind of problem like that
so then there are a variety of different
kinds of
pseudorandom generators that people
invent there's some that are based on
generalizations of the fibonacci
sequence
there's some that are based on uh
things called shift registers there are
those actually are strangely related to
the fibonacci ones
um and then there are ones that are
based on
things like uh these simple cellular
automata that i've studied a lot
uh they actually seem to be by far the
best of the ones we know right now
they're very simple programs but when
you generate their output
the output seems for all practical
purposes random
another approach that's sometimes used
is to use
a kind of a something similar to what's
used
in uh certain kinds of for certain kinds
of cryptographic
purposes so the um
a typical thing is you take
a list of numbers and um you
are then taking blocks of those numbers
and you're saying anytime
you get one zero one replace it with one
one zero or something you you have a
table
of how to replace these blocks and you
also have permutations where you say the
number that's at this position you
should exchange it with a number that's
at that position
and so you can have many rounds of this
kind of substitution and permutation
kind of approach and that was for a long
time
kind of a standard way still is a
standard way of doing kind of
certain level of cryptography a certain
level of kind of
taking the initial uh systematic data
you have and kind of grinding it up
to produce something that looks random
and so
people quite often use that kind of
system to make
an approximation to to randomness a
pseudo-random generator
and usually there's a little bit of a
trade-off between how fast you generate
the numbers and how random they're going
to be
and we've studied for example cellular
automata to try to find the ones
that generate numbers as fast as
possible while being as random as
possible
one feature of pseudorandom generators
is that you always start them off with
some seed
some initial state some initial number
and then as you generate successive
numbers
you're going from that seed number to
the first number you generate to the
next number you generate and so
on it's a chain and so
if you use the same seed you'll always
get the same chain of random numbers
and they're not really they don't look
very random if you compare
the numbers when you use the seed 100
and they use the seed 100 again you'll
get the exact same numbers
coming out for some purposes that's very
useful if you're like testing pieces of
software
then you say i want to make random tests
of this piece of software but i always
want to make the same random tests
then it's very useful to be able to seed
the random number generator
and that's a feature of pseudo-random
generators if
the way that you're generating your
randomness is by having ping-pong balls
flap around in you know in a with a
blowing
air around them um that's not something
where you can
reproduce where you can expect to run it
exactly the same again
and get the exact same ball out again
you'd have to have this very carefully
calibrated machine
you have to work out the physics
carefully to make sure that it was
repeatable so to speak
so anyway that's a little bit of the
story of random numbers
um in practice in computers
pseudo-random numbers are used all the
time
for all kinds of purposes and there's
sort of
a few little little seedings
of more less algorithmically generated
randomness like
picking particular times at which things
happen on a computer
you can pick things like i don't know
the um the bits that are coming through
the network
interface or some detail about
what's at some particular place in the
memory of the computer
or even if you have a human with you
know
interacting with a computer something
about the motion of the mouse
you know the detailed motion of the
mouse or other kinds of things
or you could even imagine something
where you have kind of a thing that's
detecting
uh let's say random radio signals that
are coming into the computer
or even detecting random molecules
sort of hitting some detector on the
computer these are kind of
external sort of physicalized sources of
randomness that you can use
and people sometimes have fun ones like
uh lava lamps that have these sort of
two
um uh that have um um
i don't actually know what's in them oil
and some other some other fluid some
other liquid
that's a slightly different color and um
as you heat the fluid you get this kind
of
convection which which leads one fluid
to come
up above the other one and then it cools
down it comes down and that happens in a
kind of random way
and people just for fun sometimes use
things like lava lamps
as their source of kind of the ultimate
source of random digits
people also imagine that they can use
quantum mechanics
to make those random digits i think
that's a more complicated thing than i
might imagine
but that's a more a more complicated
story
let's see um
gosh there's a question here
from mauricio
asking do i think that
parents should control how much time
kids spend
on computers and smartphones
uh i don't know my sample of four
children now
somewhat grown up um i
certainly um in my particular sample
maybe because they sort of were exposed
to computers all over the place
there was no reason that i could ever
see
why one should limit the amount of time
they spent
using computers and such like i think
it's really a question
of uh i mean
my general point of view and maybe this
is a
a um is uh with children and
others is sort of
make things that people want to do
rather than
preventing them from doing things that
is
if there's something that they want to
do more than
playing that seemingly rather pointless
game on their phone
then that's sort of the thing to aim for
rather than saying
oh you shouldn't play that game on your
phone so to speak
it's like well why are you playing the
game on your phone
well it's because you can't think of
anything else to do
okay well what about doing this what
about doing that
seems like a better approach now you
know of the things
people do on phones and computers and so
on
it's a little bit hard for me to
understand or know
what is kind of
of educational value in some sense
you know what is the definition of
educational value
in some sense one gets
educated in order to sort of lead one's
life in
in uh the best way one can whatever that
means
uh or perhaps you know it depends on you
know it's a rather philosophical
question what the purpose of education
is
it could be for yourself to lead
the best life that you can as you view
it for yourself
or it could be to do something that fits
best into society
or that is the most helpful to society
and those are somewhat different goals
of education
and even saying to lead the life that
you think is best
what you think is best will depend on
what you have learnt
so to speak that is you might say
i'm really happy i am just playing this
video game i know about nothing else
there's nothing else i've never learned
about
uh figuring out you know writing
uh great literature or or um going
horseback riding or something
all i know is this video game and i'm
very happy playing this video game
so it's a little bit of a a complicated
and sort of um
almost self-fulfilling or unfulfilling
question
because that which you don't know you
probably can't have an opinion about
whether
you like it or not and in some sense one
of the purposes perhaps of education
should be
to have enough exposure to things that
exist in the world
to even have an idea what you like and
what you don't like
now but what you like and what you don't
like is is deeply conditioned
by other things you've learned so just
saying hey here's this thing
you know do you like this well
it depends on how you got to this and
what other things you know
it's it's something that i think is very
hard to answer in the abstract although
although many people will have an
immediate reaction oh yeah i really like
that
and perhaps that's because of the way we
are sort of built
at a an almost physiological level you
know the particular fold in our brain in
this place
makes us really like doing this or
whatever and that's something that we're
kind of born with or maybe it is a
feature
of you know the detailed sequence of
experiences that we've had that says
i really like this or i can't stand this
so i think that you know to answer this
question
about uh uh specifically uh
phones and computers and things i mean i
you know it is a little odd
you see some kids uh interacting
via various kinds of messaging apps and
you look at the stream of communication
and it's you know
yo hi you know it seems very
it seems almost like the kind of thing
you can imagine some
species other than humans communicating
with
it doesn't seem like it's making use of
all those fine wonderful
higher cognitive capacities that humans
have
but maybe i just don't understand it and
maybe there is some great social purpose
and great sort of social understanding
that's generated by
exchanging yos and so on in just the
right way
so i think it's um uh uh
you know by the time i mean personally
i don't play video games i don't watch
television
um i uh for me personally my set of
personal objectives tends to be
ones where if i say well i've spent x
amount of time doing one of those
activities
i say that's just zero
as far as the objectives that i consider
important to myself
are concerned and so it's like that's
just time i might as well be asleep
but at least if i'm asleep it's kind of
helping my
me rejuvenate so to speak uh and you
know
again perhaps this is always a very
personal thing because
i'm one of these people who doesn't
really need
a lot of kind of down time so to speak
i'm
i'm doing things all the time and i kind
of jump from this to that
and i don't kind of need particularly
this
okay let me relax and watch television
for an hour type thing
before i do my next thing i think
perhaps other people need that i mean
i've always found
just sleeping once a day is pretty good
way to rejuvenate
uh most of the time and uh so
you know very maybe a very traditional
approach so to speak
but i'm sure it's different for other
people
let's see as a question here from
vuc is it possible to have many
internets
an internet outside of this current
internet
well you know the point of the internet
is to connect computers together
so insofar as you want to have something
where any computer can call any other
computer
it better be just one internet in the
sense that there is at least
some way to get that message from one
computer to another
now actually there are different
internets within companies
within things like governments military
organizations things like that
there are separated computer networks
where the computers within that
network communicate only with each other
and they don't communicate with the
outside world or at least they're not
supposed to
there's often one talks about there
being an air gap
there's no there are no wires that
connect those computers
inside this kind of uh walled area so to
speak
from computers outside and sometimes
people go to
extremes like if you're doing some very
secret kind of thing
you might want your computers to be such
that nothing about your computers
ever escapes to the outside world so for
example computers
produce radio emissions when they're all
the
electrons are whizzing around the
computer it's actually emitting some
amount of radio energy
because of all those electrons being
accelerated around inside the computer
and if you want in and if you really
want to keep secret what your computer
is doing
you don't want anybody even from the
outside to have some big radio antenna
they set up
which can tell oh i can tell something
about what this computer is doing
from the outside so you put it in some
metal box
through which radio signals can't get
and then you have a very
separated off computer or computer
network
that is really separated from the
existing internet now if you say oh by
the way
i want to send my friend a message well
you're out of luck
because that's a disconnected piece
that's a disconnected network
and it's sort of an interesting thing to
imagine
well the internet has a particular way
of working
where it's set up for you know computers
always have an address an ip address an
internet protocol
address um and uh like like computers at
my company
their address is all 140.177.1.7 or
something
but the 140.177 that's our piece
of the internet and all computers have
that kind of address that that's an
actually an ipv4 address
they're now longer addresses that have
more pieces in them
because you need that in order to deal
with the number of computers that exist
in the world
but this question of whether you
separate off different parts of that
network
that's uh that's a thing people do do
now
in you know in the world as the world is
there are countries that have tried to
separate off the internet
so for example china maintains a kind of
firewall
that uh prevents certain kinds of
of internet messages from getting into
china probably prevents
certain kinds of messages from getting
out from china the same happens i think
in countries like north korea it's it's
at least temporarily happened in other
countries like i think turkey did that
for a while some
other countries in that general part of
the world have done that um
at least at a partial level saying well
we'll allow
some messages to get through but
otherwise we'll have sort of a separated
version of the internet
um one can debate the question of
whether that's a good idea or not
but that's a different type of topic the
from a technical level
you can certainly just say cut all the
wires and
have this thing that is a a separate
network um
independent of of the of the standard
internet
now another question is can you make
a a sort of could you make a faster
internet even using
the internet so to speak because when
you send a message
on the internet when one computer tries
to communicate with another
it finds a route so it's going uh you
know if i try and communicate with some
computer
in maybe some other part of the world
you can actually look up there's a
utility
in unix for example called traceroute
that will show you
the route that the pieces of your
message the packets in your message will
take
to get from your computer to another
computer and you'll see it goes to this
computer that computer maybe goes
through 10 steps
to get to that other computer that
is the one you're trying to reach and
those routes
are recorded that's uh the routing
tables
which are kind of distributed throughout
the internet
and different and the computer you have
will probably have routing tables for
some other work from some
computers that it often tries to
communicate with and then it'll
if it wants to communicate with a
computer it hasn't communicated with
before
it will make queries to uh dns servers
which will then
pick up these routes and eventually it
will be told how to communicate with
that computer now is that the fastest
way to get there
well maybe not and so one of the things
that's happening
is people are trying to make kind of
overlays on top of the internet
where there are potentially quicker ways
to get
from your computer to another computer
but maybe doing that
requires routing traffic routing
messages
packets through some computer where
somebody says i don't really want all
these packets to route through my
computer
you know if you're going to route all
these packets through my computer i want
you to pay me something
and so one of the things that's
happening is the idea of so-called
tokenizing
this kind of network transmission so in
the world of blockchain and
cryptocurrencies and bitcoin and things
like that
there are starting to be currencies
where basically you are paying
in that cryptocurrency for the
for routing traffic through faster
paths than what you would get by going
through the standard internet
so you're going through the same sort of
the same wires that the internet uses
but the the details of what the hops
that you go through to get from one
place to another
they may be different and you're
essentially paying somebody to let you
go through their computer
to get to the destination you get to and
there's kind of the idea is
that there's sort of an economic system
where if you really want to
get your data through you're going to
pay more to get your data through more
quickly
and the kind of the toll road so to
speak of
of the person who has that computer that
allows you to get it through more
quickly
will um will let it go through
now there's a i mean things get very
complicated on the in the way the
internet works
there are all kinds of questions there
are ultimately the fiber optic cables
and things that are the backbone of the
internet those are owned by people
and there's sort of a question of the
way the internet works it's just like if
if there's a route and there's a fiber
that somebody has your
your traffic will be routed through that
fiber if that's what the route said
now one of the arguments that's come up
is the so-called net neutrality argument
of okay somebody owns that fiber maybe
they should give preference
to uh somebody who is indirectly paying
them or somebody they like
or or some particular kind of traffic
that is beneficial to them or
whatever else maybe there should be a
preference given at that level
and so that was a thing that was
discussed at sort of a political level
and um at this point net neutrality is
still a thing in the sense that you
can't
sort of the way the internet is set up
it's like
traffic is going through regardless of
whose traffic it is and you could
imagine a situation where
there is and again this sort of
tokenization approach is one
one branch of that kind of thing of sort
of paying to get your
messages through more quickly on sort of
an overlay on top of the internet
the other thing would be taking the
internet as it is and changing
what how much you pay to go through one
part of the internet or another part of
the internet
forcing people to do that rather than
having this kind of overlay where you
can do it if you want
so there's a a bunch of other complexity
around that
um
okay there are
questions here about um uh
okay there are questions about will
countries be able to enforce
these kinds of firewalls if they're
communicating
with satellites if people have radio
if people are using cell phones that for
example
don't or or satellite phones effectively
they'll probably be marketed as cell
phones that don't
communicate with base stations that are
on the ground but rather
low earth orbit satellites um
you know i think that that's an issue i
know that there are countries where
when you enter the country they say do
you have a satellite phone
um so i think india is one of those
countries
um and uh where people
for whatever reason have said well
there's stuff we can't control if people
are just using satellite phones
to communicate directly with satellites
um i think that's
uh an interesting question i mean at
times
people have blocked satellite
communications for example even blocking
gps
which is a satellite based system um
it's possible to do that by just having
lots of sort of random radio signals
that block out the ones that you
uh want to get from those satellites but
you know that's just the world getting
to be an even more complicated place
if you have to do things like that um
and i think
you know one certainly wonders about the
places where you know there's the rogue
fiber optic cable that's running uh i've
never heard of that
um there are some privately owned sort
of custom
fiber optic cables for example under the
atlantic um
there's one that's owned by a bunch of
finance companies
where they want to get data on you know
how did that
uh stock market trade go they want to
get that data a little bit ahead of
where other people can get the data
by sending it through their own fiber
optic cable that goes from london to new
york or whatever
um and so although i haven't heard it of
it
one can imagine cases where people could
say you know i want to break through
this kind of uh
computerized firewall around the country
that i'm in i'm going to dig this tunnel
and just put a fiber optic cable through
it
and again haven't heard of that
happening or laying such
cables uh on the ocean floor um out from
some country haven't heard of that
um but i you know that's one of the one
of the complicated things that might
happen in the world as
we go forward let's see
um there are questions here
about um
okay question from
a student what's my vision for the
future
and how do current students like the
ones we have at our summer school and
summer camp and so on
fit into that vision um
well
gosh how will the future be different
from the present
you know i think there are one feature
of human
history is technology seems to always
advance
what does that even mean in a sense what
it means is that more things get to be
done automatically
we humans imagine doing something
and then more things that we sort of
imagine
doing can just get done for us
automatically
by technology than before another thing
is that technology kind of gets more and
more sophisticated in the sense that
more and more things
we can kind of take for granted we have
you know first
we have the camera the basic camera
where you have to set everything and
it's kind of complicated to use and it
has all these different pieces and so on
and then that gradually gets automated
to the point where
it's just you pick up the camera you
press the kind of idiot button
and it takes a picture and it's a really
good picture and it's optimized
automatically for you
everything that it's doing as time goes
forward i think we can expect that more
and more of technology
uh automates things i think that um
there's in the end it kind of is a big
shining a big light
back on us humans saying okay you can do
all this stuff it's all very automatic
what do you want to do and in a sense
that is a a thing that is not a question
of technology
that's a question of philosophy of of
culture
of things like that what do you want to
do and so
i would say that um when people say well
in the future
all you ever need to know about is
technology i don't think so
i think that in a sense technologists
like me
try and build technology so you have to
know less and less about technology
so more and more is automated and more
and more is just
like the human decides what they want to
do and then the technology does it for
them
now having said that there's sort of a
question of how do you define what you
want the technology to do
how do you kind of you have this very
sophisticated artificial intelligence or
something
how do you communicate with it how do
you tell it what you want
and i've spent a big part of my life
sort of trying to understand kind of
how do we humans sort of take the things
that we think about and
move them closer to the kind of
way that that
one can define them computationally i
mean a lot of what i've been interested
in
is this way of thinking that comes from
thinking about
computers about systems that operate
according to definite rules and so on
this idea of kind of thinking about the
world computationally
defining things about the world in
computational terms
and one of the things that is for sure a
trend over the next decades
is that all these different fields of
science and other areas of human
endeavor
they all are becoming more and more
computational they're all
becoming more and more to the point
where the way you think about them
is in computational terms you're not
just saying well i roughly think this is
how it works and i've got words to
describe it
but rather here's this kind of program
that represents what's going on
and i think what we will see over the
next decades
is that more and more areas for any sort
of
x there's going to be a computational x
and for the students of today
kind of learning computational language
so that you can
interact so that you can think in those
computational terms
to do computational x that's obviously a
very important thing to do
that's you know this computational
paradigm is kind of
the big thing of the 21st century and
it's something that
is kind of the thing for people to learn
it's it's
one of the only new things fundamentally
new areas
that have sort of entered the world
since education since public education
became common 100 or so years ago it's
like
you know basic math and reading and
writing and so on those all existed
but thinking about things
computationally that's something new
that's something new of the last few
decades
and it's something that is very much
it's a very fertile approach
like for example the mathematical way of
thinking about things
that's about 300 years old and
it it's something where
knowing that way of thinking about
things is quite useful
knowing the kind of computational way of
thinking about things is even more
useful
so you know that's in terms of kind of
how to
think about things i mean like for
example things
a lot of education has to do with sort
of learning how it should be have to do
with
learning how to think about things
unfortunately
education tends to be become rather
industrial
and it's like we've got a million
students to educate how are we going to
do that
let's get everybody to do the take these
particular steps kind of on a production
line
because that's all we can do given that
we've got a million students to
educate and you know one can argue
whether it's better to sort of educate
really well
10 000 students and uh
you know the other ones it's not not do
so well by them
or whether it's more important to sort
of give
equal education i think that's a
complicated question
it's a complicated story people have
made different choices
at different times in history people
have sometimes meant to make one choice
and actually ended up making a quite
different choice
i think that my point of view is
it tends to be the case that things you
want to learn are things you should
learn
and things you profoundly don't want to
learn well
it's worth learning some of those things
because at least in my experience even
things i didn't want to learn
back when i was a kid turns out it was
quite useful that i know them
um but i think that one learns much
better if one wants to learn what one is
learning
so to speak and in so far as one can
find things one wants to do
that are kind of going to be fulfilling
to one
and where one can kind of just those are
the things one really learns the most
about
one is going to be much more receptive
to learning things
but i think it's uh you know i i do tend
to think
that learning how to think about things
learning how to
get things done how to go from
nothing to something how to go from how
to sort of have an idea
that where you just say this is a
general category of thing you're trying
to do
have an idea about it um these are
things that are very useful to know
i mean thinking about things it's not
necessarily a story of how do you get
the right answer to the math quiz
because actually you can do that pretty
mechanically it doesn't require kind of
the the sort of overall thinking about
things i mean i think the thing that
somewhat characterizes sort of this
overall thinking
is you know there may be a particular
topic you're studying
but are all those other things you know
also somehow floating around in your
mind
and able to inform the answers that you
get
or is it just oh i'm i'm focused on this
one particular thing
and that's the only path i'm going to
follow and i know mechanically
how to do that particular thing but i
kind of don't
all these other things i know don't sort
of enter i mean i'm sort of fond of
saying
you know one of the important things is
to not disengage the thinking apparatus
whatever you're thinking about even if
it's something which you might imagine
was kind of this very rote mechanical
type of thing
i think um uh
it's some um well there are lots of
lots of things about sort of how the
world can and should evolve
and what
you know how sort of uh society
develops and what people decide is
important in society
and there are a lot of very complicated
dynamics about which
we don't currently have a huge amount of
science um
a huge amount of predictability maybe
there's more predictability than we
imagine maybe there's not
about sort of the trends of history and
what things people will sort of imagine
are a good idea and what things they
won't imagine are a good idea
um i don't know uh i think
i think again it's like there will
always be the unexpected there'll always
be things
for which we don't have a sort of
predictive theory
and the question is what do you do under
those circumstances
and the more people know how to think
about things
in uh in a in the best way
the better that will come out and i
think you know what does it mean to
think about things in the best way
well one thing is know as much as you
can if you say
i only know these few things and i'm
going to figure out everything just from
these few things
that's not a formula for figuring out
things in the best way
so for example one example of that is
history
there are many things to know from
history
history doesn't typically precisely
repeat itself
so just knowing this is what happened
200 years ago
when such and such the thing came about
doesn't necessarily tell you what's
going to happen now
but knowing that is tremendously
important for getting some idea some
intuition
some way of thinking about what some uh
what what's happening now and so i think
that the um
uh this this sort of idea of
well the more you know the more you're
going to be able to figure out
this is a pretty useful principle and
even within one's own life i mean i
i'm kind of an ancient person by this
point but you know i've had lots of
experience with lots of different kinds
of things
and when i have to figure something out
a lot of the conclusions i come to
will be based on actual experiences that
i've had oh i saw something
a bit similar 25 years ago and this is
how that worked out
let me use that knowledge of what
happened before
to inform how i think about it now
all right i think um we are running out
of time for today
and that may be a good uh uh question
to to end on here um and
um let's um
let's wrap it up for now and um
thanks for joining us and uh hope to see
you all
next week